today we have adopted these very
important decisions regarding refit a
program to be sure that our legislation
is fit for purpose
it is lighter it is cheaper and it is
simpler i think at european level we
have to focus on when europe has value
there are many areas where
we need european regulation but there
are other issues that can be better
dealt with at national or regional level
and i'm happy that there was such a
consensus in the commission regarding
this agenda for better regulation we
have already been working on it for
instance reducing the initiative burden
on companies by more than 25 percent i
hope now that all in europe
also in the governments in member states
they are committed to this modernization
approach to the simplification approach
that we need so that we make life easier
for our companies for our citizens and
that we are
promoting growth and jobs in europe our
priority i repeat is growth and jobs